[Music]
[Applause]
okay welcome back to the true Geordie
podcast today's guest is a former under
cover police officer she's a little bit
nervous today you're right I am I'm
nervous it's so funny after the things
that I've read about you the things that
you've done
us when you have literally been around
hard-nosed criminals who could kill you
at any moment and then little old maze
into a minute I know but I'm being
really me now yeah I'm like stood in
naked basically yeah not literally no
not literally
so the thing that got my brain going
before when we were talking is the we
see on the news that this person's been
taken down for doing this to children or
what you know and it's horrifying but
you're a person who's literally met
these kind of people before and it got
my brain thinking and it made me wonder
if have you ever thought like
how many people there are out there that
we interact with on a day-to-day basis
who may have those kind of things on
their computer or these predilections as
they say to children and stuff like that
is do you think it's more common than
any of us would ever think without a
doubt right 100 yeah and it's funny
because you think don't you lay on the
media and in like movies and drama
series those sorts of people have a
certain look and we'll say don't we all
look at that pedophile look at them
glasses like oh I bet you know we people
do make them comments yeah you're
stereotype yeah of course and some
believe it or not do look like that they
really do look like that
um yeah I should have known you look
like it but you turn up and you go oh I
wonder what one it is but like no but
some people like like I know I know
people that I would never in a million
years in my real life in a million years
be involved in that stuff and they have
been wow I had no clue and when you're
face to face with them like have any of
them been a lot more normal and nice
than what you'd ever think like because
we I kind of think that these are like
evil villains in movies but they
ingratiate themselves into the world so
they they can't always be like that
a lot of them work like have normal
lives like completely normal lives we I
remember one case I worked on he was a
family man he had a wife a couple of
kids a mistress a mystery he was
pregnant
um but he was a pedophile really like
you would never when you say and and
when you say beautiful do you mean like
because there's different definitions
isn't there do you mean like really
young children sort of thing uh he was
like teen young teen girl really yeah he
liked school girls
um this particular guy but I have
interacted with other people where
you're that I'm dealing with them as a
teenager and then when they've been
arrested they've gone and obviously
viewed everything that's on their their
hardware and it's got baby stuff on it
like that how can how can a human being
think that's acceptable as a decent
human being how can you think being a
baby yeah like come on there's even
um people who had been chemically
castrated I think in the Louisa Road
accidentally but you're still like
you're still denying so much truth there
even after this has happened so is it a
sexual thing or is it a mental health
thing where they've got this like
um you know deep-rooted issue that's
beyond sex almost like they are just
yeah I don't know I mean it's got to be
a bit of both hasn't it like if you if
you're saying normal but not normal
because that's not the right word but
like semi-normal yeah how many of us
know more yeah everyone has a kink as a
legend yeah but like that that's like
you would know in your brain that's
wrong and you just wouldn't do it surely
you just would not do it so have you had
to go through their computers before and
look at these images that they've had on
on file that period would not be dealt
with by me because I'm just there as the
covert asset but
other officers would have gone through
it and they obviously they're there to
grade it this that's one person's job is
to grade how bad it is how severe it is
like that must yeah when I was a kid uh
you know how you have like your mom's
friends and stuff like that and they
they her her fella was a a copper and he
used to have to be involved with this
sort of stuff in a detective sense and
he had very bad mental health of course
uh leaving the police officers like uh
it really seemed to screw him up like
just how much he'd had a witness an
endure so I mean there was those people
deserve metal stuff to go through that
because they are trying to save these
kids in one way or another to stop this
being but does it I mean this is a sort
of deeper question but does it ever feel
like
trying to empty the save of the bucket
like they're just it's it's almost like
kind of stopping drugs you know you're
trying to stop the drug dealers on the
streets but the reality is is like the
the the thirst for it is not going to go
away no and the problem you've got as
well now is obviously people do live
online if you go on to like the dark web
it's there like and
you can't get rid of it like so it's
there it's more accessible now than it
would have been 10 30 years ago you know
people can you know they can they can
get it they can access it
um and obviously there's a difference
between looking at it and physically
partaking in it but you know and I think
people are talking about it more now you
know like we see obviously overseas in
in particular countries and it's been in
the Press recently about how Gary
Glitter is now back inside like people
like him in his prime it wasn't spoken
about it's only now because we all live
online and we're encouraged to be vocal
you know there's platforms for people to
speak anonymously whereas before there
wasn't it would be me and you would have
to sit and talk like this or on the
phone rather than put it online Gary
Glitter for those who don't know was a
pop star back in the 80s or something
like that yeah I mean I'm too young I
wouldn't know yeah both of us thanks yes
and um Jimmy Savile uh was it he was in
the Jimmy Savile ring essentially he was
part of that whole thing and it does
make you wonder how you know that many
people knew and it still stayed a secret
I mean you know there was people
um like Jill dando killed who were
allegedly about to expose all of that as
someone who's been in in the cops how
how lightly do you think that those
cover-ups had the help of some police
officers I think maybe back in the day
there was cover-up maybe I don't know
this is just what I think
um there could have been cover-ups on
certain things nowadays I don't think so
at all like I don't think the police is
what it was I think there's a there's an
issue right now though because there's
in the last I don't want to say like two
years there's been police officers
convicted of horrific things there was a
guy who had been convicted of 50 attacks
and uh he'd been in the cops for years
and what is it like for you being a part
of the police and so well not now but so
closely linked to them when you hear
these things honestly it makes you feel
like physically sick it's it's that one
the one that you saw about Sarah everard
I mean what
like who why he was flushing people
before that right yeah so there was like
there was things that they had to be
like okay we got to watch this guy yeah
for a start you shouldn't be a cop if
you're doing that but then no one
flagged it no and you know what winds me
up as well he was he was in a position
of power he had that warrant card when
you get your warrant card he said you're
gonna laugh and think I'm being cheesy
but you feel really proud and like I'm
serving the obviously it was a queen
there and I'm serving the queen this is
like this is a big deal the privilege
yeah not everybody gets it and you feel
really proud to have it and for him to
go around and
Flash's warrant cards in fact so then
get her in his car I think that's just
that's Twisted on it and honestly no one
hates a bad cop more than a good cop I
can't take I know
so many good cop more good cops and bad
cops and everyone's opinion of him and
the other one is exactly the same like
the scumbags absolute scumbags and the
police have got a massive problem the
new leaders are the right people for the
job but we had a point in the place
where you could join a rank so a senior
management position just because you've
got a degree
like that makes no sense how can you be
making decisions and be the ones that
I've got a hold in the purse paying
money for courses and making big
decisions on things when you've not even
been in the roles that you're making
decisions about that makes no sense to
me and that's that's half the problem A
lot's happened in the last probably
eight years ten to eight years because
they the police made some bad decisions
with recruitment recruitment's a huge
issue
that's a massive massive issue and I
genuinely think that I think that the
new uh commission is going to work and I
think the new assistant commission is
going to work
but the whoever's I don't know whose
decision it was to let these people with
a degree become senior management but
they lost a lot of good cops over that
period because nobody trusted their
management nobody had any faith in their
management and the management literally
screwed the police I remember watching
some of the interviews and you're
watching them going you are having a
mayor here you know where someone's
digging their own grave and you're just
watching them like you look like you're
Clueless yeah and they are they're so
clueless they are they they
they've stopped it now but this whole if
you're a graduate you can join as an
inspector thing was just stupid like I
don't know if someone would have got
promotion off the back of that sort of
brings me on to what what was it about
you that you were attracted to go that
down that road I never wanted to be a
police officer
I wanted to be a power suit wearing
lawyer who lived in wapping and had a
sports car
um but that never happened and um I just
kind of fell into my dad was a policeman
he was an inspector oh really um acting
inspector will tell me off for sound
inspector because he retired as a DS but
um that wasn't why I joined
um when I was 15 I got attacked
um I was at a party
and my boyfriend of the time at the time
he um was hit over the back of the head
of a bottle and knocked out then they
used the bottle they'd broken over the
back of his head to slash my friend's
throat Jesus throat not throat and
that's my East London coming up from his
th
um and the next thing I remember is I
woke up the next morning in hospital
um and they'd knock me out I had a
broken nose I actually come off worse
broken nose cheek damaged my jaw and
some broken ribs and was there a reason
for that long plays wrong time so no
confrontation we'd been at a party and
everyone had left the party we were
literally just walking home like
literally no reason for it
um but that was my first thing I grew up
so I was born in East London and grew up
in dagenham and if you know dagenham
it's not the greatest of places
um and the police aren't they're not
disrespected but they wasn't you know no
one said it openly I want to be a police
officer at school
um and I just thought I really I was
really impressed by what I'd seen from
the police that were dealing with my
case I couldn't believe it I thought
they were really good and I thought they
were really kind to me I was only 15.
um and we had to go to Crown Court and
they were really nice to me and I
thought oh they're really nice oh so
they caught them oh yeah yeah they went
away they went to prison wow um but that
was my first interaction with police
apart from my dad and my dad didn't come
home and tell us what he'd been doing
because I wouldn't have listened anyway
so when you're when you're waking up and
you're going through that and you're
worrying about your friends who've
nearly been killed it I mean a throat
slashing is close to death isn't it yeah
I don't know how he got through that
yeah for a 15 year old girl what kind of
like recovery did you go through
mentally or that could you remember
I think because some people would have
been scared to go outside like PTSD I
know people have been through traumatic
things like that they they're never the
same after that but you went the other
way yeah I don't know I just thought I
didn't really I don't think about I try
not to dwell on it and it's only now I'm
older that I do dwell on things that I
overthink things really so when we got
to the hospital my mum and dad split and
my dad turned up and then my mum turned
out my mum's like four foot two she's
like tiny but very vocal and um the
police actually told her she didn't stop
because she was the guys that had done
it turned up at the hospital
to finish it off apparently I don't even
know what that means but it's mental
because of yourself yeah so they all got
um Nicks but my mum nearly got arrested
because she said that she was gonna kill
him and she was gonna see she wasn't
gonna kill him but you know like because
I turn a phrase I'm gonna get them and
I'm gonna but my dad's really calm so my
dad was just like
he didn't really care what they were up
to he was just concentrating on me and I
remember he said to me um I need to tell
you something and you're not gonna like
it but they're gonna they're gonna have
to take your clothes off because I think
you've been stabbed and I was like what
do you mean and he was like there's a
lot of blood and they don't know where
it's coming from
it wasn't just for my nose like I had a
light jacket on it's like it looked a
lot you're not going to want to take
your clothes off but they're going to
take your clothes off
um so he was like really calm how did
you feel with that did he help a lot
yeah my dad's just chilled like he's and
I'd better laugh at me for saying this
but if my even now at my age now if my
dad says it's right I still I'm like my
dad said
so we were arguing the other day about
some lights for our patio and I said but
my dad said you can do it and he went
I'll get your dad over to do it yeah so
I trust my dad a lot like he's very like
level and he thinks properly he doesn't
he doesn't ever shoot from the hip you
know he just really thinks and he's very
light methodical and makes him a good
police officer then yeah so what about
the police was the thing that got you in
there and then what was it like just
starting out my dad actually said then
there's a recruitment for women and I
was like no I want to go to UNI and I
want to be a lawyer and he was like
I think you should I don't know if he
had no faith in me getting the grades or
if I wasn't going to be a good lawyer
but he was just like I think you should
give it a go so I literally just applied
um and got a phone call to say can you
come up for yeah like loads of
Assessments like interviews and all that
sort of stuff my dad took me to all of
them well you're just like on the beat
doing the normal stuff and and then at
some point you're thinking undercover
how does that get initiated I finished
tendon and then you have to pick your
Borough and I went to Tower hamlets
which is where I'm my family are all
from I know it really well I love it
um I loved loved loved being a copper on
sour hamlets I thought it was brilliant
oh really and you go from one extreme to
the other like you've got Canary wolf
whopping it's like crazy at wealth like
extreme well then you've got like step
knee and it's really not wealth at all
it literally is one extreme to the other
so you're constantly busy and the stuff
that you're like dealing with it can be
you know high-end robberies or high-end
burglaries with like tens of thousands
of pounds of stuff stolen or it could be
you know
um FGM or like do you know what I mean
range marriage so it goes from one extra
large what does that what do you mean so
on our Borough arranged marriage was
quite a
um
common thing where younger not young
girls not necessarily you're always
young but like you know teens late teens
would be their marriage would be
arranged for them they said their
parents would meet with other parents
and the boy and the girl would be never
me and then they'd meet on their wedding
day is that illegal no it's not illegal
if they're winning I was just wondering
why you guys were involved in because a
lot sometimes the girls wouldn't want
that to happen oh so they're reporting
and say I don't want this to happen so
then it'll become forced marriage rather
than arranged marriage yeah so that's
you know what happens when you turn up
to that situation
he's a bit here you I I remember the
first one I was a bit like I don't know
what to do here this is like what you
see on the table not really dressed for
this no I was like I don't know what's
happening but a young girl so it was a
girl at school actually she'd reported
to a teacher so she was a sixth former
so she was of age she was able to do it
but still like 17 but she didn't want to
yeah um and she was worried that her
family were going to take her back to
their home country and marry her off in
the summer and she tried to give her
passport to her teacher and said if you
if you have my passport I can't go her
mother's like oh don't worry there's
that quick turnaround one 24 hours oh
yeah yeah but I felt like I remember
thinking what is this like I don't know
what to do when you're reaching out
you're a teacher and you're worried
about getting put on a plane like that
I've watched some documentaries about
that yeah it is if you I mean it's
against human rights essentially sad if
you're willing for that that's
absolutely cool like that's fine but not
if you don't want to do it and you're
kind of family putting the pressure on
and that's not cool but there are
actually dedicated teams on each bar
that deal with it now well okay so what
kind of reaction did you get when you
were a person through the doors like
well I put the ring down yeah well no I
didn't get to the wedding obviously
um I'm quite a good wedding guest
I'm a good gift buyer does anyone have a
reason why these two shall not be wet
what actually yeah but no so she'd
reported it and I went I was first
officer on the scene and spoke to her
and she told me what happened so
obviously I'd written down what she told
me immediately and then specialist
officers come and they deal with it so
you don't always deal with everything
even though you're the first I've seen
the families have been saying go out
here yeah the families some of the
families aren't always happy that you
turn up but that's in everything that's
in everything you know you turn up I
remember once turning up to Nick this
kid for uh drug offenses and he's
grandma and I'm not even joking his
grandma was proper giving it in my face
I was thinking
yeah she's so sweet lovely but you're
shouting them in you obviously don't
understand what we're doing here but one
afternoon I got my Governor said then
tomorrow when you come in for night Duty
which is my favorite shift because it's
proper Lively just bringing cities like
just where your cities don't come in
uniform like these plain clothes and I
was like wow what was happening and he
said you and a colleague are going to go
out in plain clothes and I was like
I'm So Undercover like I thought that
was under I had no idea that there was a
difference between covert and undercover
I thought I thought I was so deep like
yeah no one was going to see me yeah
this is a movie and me and my colleague
went out but we're so naive obviously
the criminals all know what all the
unmarked car indexes are so they saw us
coming before we even saw them
um so we did it for a little one we got
some quite a good arrests we did it for
a bit and then one weekend we were doing
it and I had this great idea that we
should walk and not drive and he was
like what and he had much more service
than me and he was like we're not
walking and I was like no I'm coming
it'll be really good we'll be able to
just literally sneak up on them and we
were literally walking around all like
the Estates and getting in the
stairwells and watching them serving up
and then just nicking them and it was
like the evidence was so overwhelming
the governor was very happy because our
rest rate was so high CPS were charging
him with P possession with intensive
Supply
um which is hard to prove but it was
like whenever you just walked over was
in plain clothes it was authorized by
the borough commander and we've nicked
him and he's a known drug dealer he's
got all this intelligence and it was
unbelievable
um do you get a lot of credit for that
yeah quite a lot
um you know the thing that striking us
about here is how excited you are
recounting these memories and you know I
think when we all watch Netflix at home
there's a little bit of everyone who
thinks yeah I'd love to be a cop do you
know what I mean and but then there's a
part of me that often wonders like is
there something wrong with us for
getting in like excited by such dark
[__] essentially you know like
um do you have a question you're selling
me like not people aren't normally
because it's one thing me sitting
watching Netflix you are actually doing
it and you're not the biggest person so
like you know you're putting yourself in
a quite a precarious position at times I
would imagine like was there times where
people would confront you and you'd be
like [__] man I've only got one copper
here and there's five of them or what
you know yeah and it sounds so silly and
people have said to me before I suppose
you make you think the uniform made you
sort of Untouchable and that's not true
but I didn't of course sometimes you do
feel scared because that's natural and
you should feel scared because otherwise
there'd be something a bit wrong with
you if he wasn't sometimes scared
but yeah there was instances where I
would walk into things and think what
have I just done that one side the
Geezer kicked off slips a disc in my
back
but I thought I could go and just get in
and like bring him back to the station
which is really now stupid you're a very
confident young woman for sure I just
thought oh it'd be all right like I
didn't really have much of fear then but
when I was walking up there was a
particular chap who was um a prom Nom so
a prominent nominal so he was well known
we all knew who he was and I saw him
knocking you know at the bottom of some
of the Estates you get like these black
doors and it's like an electrical
cupboard I saw him knocking on that and
I thought what's he doing and then I
like looked then he the door opened and
he went in I thought oh I'm having
something like that so I went straight
over and I knocked on the door and they
let me in
but when I got in there was about 10 of
them in there smoking crack
and me in uniform but all right that's
surprised and he hated me this guy as
well like he knew who I was and I was
and so I just went straight for him
because when you say went for him what
does that mean that to arrest him
they're all sitting in there smoking
crack are they interfering or is he are
they just letting you get on with it uh
well it's sort of spilled I pressed my
emergency button because I knew straight
like this he's gonna go sit up if it's
gonna go wrong so we've all Spilled Out
the electrical cupboard I've pressed my
Emma button and that clears the airway
so everyone can anyone impresses that
everyone can hear you across your bar
after 10 seconds so normally you just
shout out wherever you are they know
who's radio number is so they know what
officer is so I just shouted out where I
was a medium of these just resisting
arrest because obviously a crack on him
and he didn't want to get nuked again
so really were like scrapping and he's
just like jumping on me he was much
bigger than me and I just went down like
as soon as my back went I was like that
was me out and it felt like it was ages
until you said you were out as in flat
out I was on the floor yeah no no I was
conscious and I still had one cuff on
and I was just not letting go of him I
was like it was skinny really skinny but
massive and I'm not having it I'm not
having you go Jesus um and he was
actually my first arrest like years
before so he really hated me
um and it just seemed that we our paths
crossed a lot yeah what was that first
the rest like
was there a thrill
Ed
at the time because I just was so happy
to have the arrest
um it was brilliant but when I look at
it now I'm like oh that's well there
could have been so much more to be
getting on with than that it was
leftover of car radio in Brick Lane and
like if you know Brick Lane there's
quite a lot of Nick stuff down there
bikes and stuff yeah I think one of the
things that frustrates me about the
police is um like I got stopped for uh
having a couple of Giants on me once and
uh
and you know I'm a tax paying Citizen
and stuff like that and there was a
whole load of police stopping everyone
who walked past and checked on their
bags and stuff and um the dog [__]
ran over at a million the one time in my
life where I wasn't happy to see a dog
because I love dogs and I was like yeah
okay then so they go through my bag but
I'm just like look in the 20 cops
just getting the odd like odd joint of
the odd thing here and there and it just
it it it made me be like come on yeah is
this your is this really what you've
been sent out to do and also for them
I'm like surely they're saying you guys
thinking and this is what we're signed
up for yeah you know I I did wonder how
often police feel because even when I
was talking to them there was a there
was an air of trepidation about me
because they were like I don't want to
[__] fight you for two giants but
also there was an air of like they felt
a bit ashamed I think yeah they actually
felt a bit like
sorry man you know what I mean that was
like yeah no death that is that is a
real genuine what you said there about
how they would have felt that's
completely genuine I've had that where
you feel
oh life you're just a harmless like yeah
just off you go don't worry about it
like just put them down the dry you know
yeah you know but a lot of that will
depend on if it's an operation so if
they've been you know drafted in for
that they have to get results because
well yeah expect the bosses of the
bosses that aren't qualified to sign
this stuff off well that was what went
in my head it's like okay so I'm looking
at let's say 20 people there with dogs
and all of that and I'm like the amount
of money you guys have spent on your day
here yeah there's no way the returns
account for what you've done so what is
it just a it like it felt like a
non-uniform day for them like don't sit
there all day and do nothing you know
what I mean and yeah that that is where
the public I feel a bit frustrated by it
um especially when my tax bill comes in
yeah um I think it's Justified though
like I don't like this like you say and
the public don't know they only know
what's released unless you physically go
through it yourself like so you've seen
it your first hand but when they release
them statistics and say oh on this day
we did a massive drug operation and we
got this many we see this much amount of
this number of drugs we've got this many
convictions the public are amazing
they're doing their job but what they
don't know is they're stopping people
like you with two joints I interviewed a
undercover uh cop years ago and he
basically threw his undercover work uh
in his was all um he was a little sort
of um
what's the word little skinny guy
um yeah yeah and he he was very uh good
at just being like the Giza who was
buying the drugs or whatever and it led
him to feel like
he basically totally changed his stunts
he felt like he was basically
not getting the right people like the
people who were using the drugs who are
in his eyes pathetic and not in a not in
a discriminatory way but you know just
he felt sorry for them yeah he was like
why am I taking down you when the real
problem is far higher up and Out Of
Reach and he he basically changed his
sons and he said the only way
around this is to decriminalize all
drugs and actually give people support
now obviously you've done a bit of this
and you know you said true there is that
how you feel yeah but only now I've left
I think a lot of
and you know that it's not them and even
the dealers that you're bringing down
they're just the footmen yeah Small
Potatoes these the real people that
you're never getting there yeah a real
businessmen who have legitimate
businesses and that's why their
businesses are so successful on that
that track because they know what
they're doing they're businessmen but
you ain't getting near them yeah not in
a million years are you getting near
them separate companies different names
all sorts of things yeah but you're not
getting near them but I only only when I
left and somebody sat and I had a chat
um it's actually a massive big agency
and I
they explained their point about
legalizing drugs and you know making it
safe making having safe rooms for
injection and all stuff like that and I
was before I was like no no if you break
the law that's it if you break the law
you know that's a risk you're making
that decision
and they explained their side I thought
actually you know what
are you all right because I'd go and buy
gear in a stairwell
from a kid it would be a kid like 16 17
18 year old not all the time but
sometimes
after about I don't know what depending
on how long the operation would last
after a couple of months of me will keep
buying from that same person they'd get
nicked when they get nicked someone else
just fills their shoes that doesn't stop
that doesn't break down the supply of
drugs in that area they just get someone
else to go and do that job little kid in
it I mean he's probably got a little
brother who's two years younger or a
mate or whatever and he's like oh cool
the spottery I'll be sitting there yeah
and that's genuinely how it works and it
was only when I thought about it like
that I thought that is ridiculous
actually like but when you're in the
police I don't like saying this but
you're a little bit institutionalized of
course you are because you're like a dog
you're telling me all the time oh well
done you've got a massive result oh
amazing so when I'm getting the praise
on the pat on the head I'm going to keep
going back to do that because they liked
it when I did that last time so I'm just
going to keep doing it and Everyone
likes to hear well done yeah yeah it's
true and when you're so amazing send
over and she'll do it and I'm like yeah
I'll go like I never said no I was like
yeah I'll go and sometimes I didn't even
know what I was doing like I'd be like
yeah I'll go I'll go just send me I'll
do it and off I'd go
but on them you must have been a dream
employee for that reason I was probably
yeah not not when I went for a divorce
but because he was that was greasy but I
just thought well someone's got to do it
I'll do it and like you said then like
Everyone likes being told they're doing
well and maybe I hate using the whole
female thing but maybe because I was a
female I'm all my all my colleagues were
male
in that unit and they're like and they I
thought they were really cool by the way
when I did my course and they were
telling me their stories about the stuff
they'd done I was like oh that is so I
would never be able to do that that's
amazing I was so brave and then I wanted
to be a part of their clerk so I thought
well the only way to get that is to just
do all the jobs and when they're telling
you nice one you're like oh I'm getting
respect from people I respect yeah like
I'm this is amazing and then they're
like do you want to come for a drink and
I'm like well I can come on your drinks
like you yes please like yeah and I
thought we have made it I really
appreciate you being honest about that
because it's not easy to admit when
you've done things or said things that
you look back at and you cringe a little
oh yeah but we've all done that yeah and
it's very like you fella you were
climbing the ladder and this is how the
police and the Army and many other
things that are difficult but that you
sometimes end up doing things that maybe
you look back at like I've interviewed
soldiers who've been to war who like
they're like what was I doing that for
now you know what I mean so you know I
respect you for admitting and also like
the part that the the issue the the
elephant in the room that these laws are
there
um is that people want to get high and
that is never going to go away so to to
deny that and to make it illegal you're
you're denying people an inevitability
because people don't want to be in the
Consciousness all the time and um and
unfortunately it is like poverty in the
in the the people right the way down who
are the ones who get locked up yeah you
know they never they can never follow
the money high enough because those
people seem to be connected almost to
the system you know like if you look
into um I had a guy on the podcast who
he looked into Bill Clinton his
involvement in the drug trade and it
blew my mind this was the president of
the United States we've currently got
Joe Biden in America who got the
dinosaur that he is who his son's laptop
is or you know yeah the amount of
cover-ups that go on when when you're
too high up to almost be touched it's
staggering and people like you are just
trying to do a good job for the
community and you you know you don't get
told that at the start otherwise who
would do it no and the drug stuff is
like you said and it's 10 a penny like
and that's like people go oh you're so
brave the heroine and the crack stuff
yeah that's what I actually had to
engage in my brain and actually work but
anyone like the coke stuff so you don't
get them jobs so going by giving a pub
or a club until you've proven yourself
on the crap jobs like the street stuff
really so when you get anyone can kind
of power and get gear like you just walk
in and you know who's serving up don't
you just have to look around you go I'll
go over there yeah so there was no
particular skill
but you're saying it was harder to do
the heroin and stuff so much harder
because it's not my natural habitat you
know I need to look why would I if I
went in there looking like myself they'd
be like
so how did you change your appearance in
your and your act like was there things
you do you probably won't believe that
it could get worse but I would change
the way I speak I have the worst accent
I know but you know I wouldn't speak
like this I completely understand I
would adapt to the people I'm talking to
um my clothes were pretty horrendous I
did find a pair of old TNS in my mum's
um shed and they were pretty in a bad
state but you would wear them I stunk my
hair wouldn't be washed for days and
people could just put baby oil in it I
go well that smells nice like that's not
gonna work is it so I won't wash my hair
my teeth would not I've got quite white
teeth so
I mean I've spent a lot of time trying
to get them to look like that
but you know you don't want to go the
bright white teeth if you know what
heroin and crack users don't have very
nice teeth I guess you do get function
in heroin users and you do get
functioning crack users but it's rare in
it the ones I'm trying to get to aren't
um so I would just look a complete State
you know no nice nails did you do any
Research into this I talked to anyone to
figure this out yeah
yeah yes
um so
so because it was so long ago there
wasn't like online wasn't we didn't
really go online as much as we do now
like you know Facebook was all quite new
and
um but there was a thing on uh I think
it was E4 or channel four I think it was
then called um ask Frank
and it was all about drugs and like I
was like oh this is really good it tells
you all these stories like case studies
and then I would speak I would literally
go into custody at the police that
bethnal green police station I'll take
like look on the border who's in and I
say to my sergeant who's in for drugs
and he'd be like you're mental and I
would just go and speak to him like how
did you how did you get into this like
what happened to you and some of their
stories were like
oh like there's no some I remember one
guy I'd actually arrested him but he was
with Nixon for crack
and he was a high fly-in in the 80s like
a high-flying yuppie worked in the city
um his brother had nicked some money off
of his mum so their mum had been had
money stolen off by one of her sons and
he'd hit his brother
Fair one and he got arrested but he'd
cause brain damage to the brother
because he got arrested and put in
prison and he got on drugs in prison and
that now he came out fully fully on
crack no job no hell I understand that
you know if you're locked up and you're
going from someone who's a high flyer
and all of a sudden life feels hopeless
you don't want to have to live in that
reality so you're checking out as best
you can yep and he said he would use
Coke sometimes at work because everybody
did he said yeah and I was like that's
I looking at him it sounds awful but
looking at him I would never in a
million years have thought that was his
life before because he does not look
like that now you know he's sitting in
Whatley Street Market in the underground
car park smoking crack
but he had a massive lovely apartment
and like the car it was like proper
Yuppie like what you would imagine off
the Telly and I felt so I felt sorry for
him did you have to ever try any hard
drugs when in in pretending to be in
that life
and but it was uh I was asked to a lot
by the people I was buying from that
happened quite a lot oh did you get out
of that if it was heroin and crack I
used to try and use the boyfriend lion
because buying it for your boyfriend
yeah oh no I can't it's my for my man
like I can't do that I need to hurry up
let's go let's go that's a reasonable
excuse though yeah and a lot of the time
they would just leave you alone because
they think you've got a boyfriend and
he's massive yeah he's really big
but with the coke staff
um I had a couple like day or two in
front of each other and I would just go
I'm not doing that I'm a girl I'm a lady
I don't do that I'm not doing anything
like no my nose rounds or something and
then I just run off to the toilet and
just put it in my pocket wow but yeah
and I remember once I was actually in a
pub and the guy followed me in the
toilet and I thought oh come on and he
was like come on have a tour of wine and
I was like I've got my own and I used to
just play a bit stupid so they just
think she's just weird so you've never
tried it ever I've never done a drug in
my life I've bought more drugs than
anyone I know and I've never even smoked
a joint and I'm not even I would die
like seriously it's so funny
I can't say all my friends because
that's not fair but out of a lot of
people I know I'm the only one that's
never tried it in anything yeah it's
funny because when when look I've got me
two or coppers and that like the glance
I went to school with and stuff and like
some of the best stand-up guys I've ever
met but equally they say like there's a
bit of a culture in the police have like
to be to be in the police it's a bit
like a lot of these sort of jobs where
you're going to be in any sort of danger
you're not quote unquote normal you are
on the edge a little bit you have to
have the fact that you want to deal with
those kind of people every day all day
yes you're going to get those straight
edge people but you are probably going
to get some
Wild Boys in there as well so did you
witness police officers who you were
like you're a [__] copper is this is
this you is it yeah there was actually
when I was in uniform there was a guy
and he was like a bit of a cannon like
I'm in base smash the door in once and
I'm going to it's not that one it's that
one
but he wouldn't listen because I was
like young in service and it was just a
welfare check anyone else would have
knocked on the door hello anyone in
there so God knows what he got up to
I'll do it because he was just coming
into work just like a fool in a china
shop and there's a rumor that they're
all sleeping together as well that's the
often thing
um you've just looked at me like yeah
that does that does happen a little bit
I think that is in any but that is true
there's a lot of that culture and
because if I was going to date a cop I
would be like nah because I already know
you're around too many Alpha meals
there's just too much going on there it
is true there is quite a
I guess if you're sitting in a car all
day and you're talking about your life
before you know you're like oh we've got
this in common oh we've got that and
then you go home maybe uh some guy who's
doesn't connect with you on that level
and all of a sudden you're feeling more
of a connection to this new person or
whatever yeah it happens doesn't it
think about men it's as if a female
police officer looks good in uniform and
we're just walking that's not none if
we're just walking past that in the
street you will kind of notice it a bit
more on it she could tell you what to do
we couldn't shoot like there's a little
bit of a little yeah sorry this is on my
[__] up brain works I should tell you
actually of a funny story because it
will make you laugh when I was on my
covert calls you know I said about that
syndrome where you're in a bubble when
you're just so like immersed in what
you're doing in your own little world
they um this is really bad there was a a
scene where you have to do a call so you
act out a proper deployment so when
you're deployed you get a set of
instructions from your senior
investigating officer they redo your
instructions you sign them they sign
them and it's basically to cover their
backside so that if
if for example you do what some other
covert officers do and they're going to
have a baby with someone they've told
you quite right like you know you've
signed to say you're not allowed to do
that you just had to have a baby with
someone as in have a baby with someone
you're undercover right and yeah what
you've infiltrated what he did yeah
Behind Enemy Lanes yeah but wow so when
that happens that really helps yeah you
said some officers not even just one
it's out in the Press so I can say that
oh wow no no I mean like I'll send you
the link
I'm certainly not I mean I'm surprised
is but now that you mention it yeah like
men be like that
um but he was fully like in in did he
just leave behind the old life and was
just like actually I think I prefer this
yeah wow we get instructions to say do
not do this you're we've told you you
haven't where you must not do this and
then you sign it and on the course like
read me my instructions I went off did
my role play come back and then I we had
a cork scenario where I have to go
through my deployment like I'm in court
as a covert officer which is actually
quite scary
when we was in the courtroom I just sat
there and I thought oh shoot I've
written the wrong date on my because I
just signed it but my senior
investigating officer for this this
pretend deployment they told me he was
from Portugal and he was over to see how
the Met uh teach covert operations and
I'm not gonna lie he was he was a 10
like he was saying it was like I thought
I love it he was really handsome yeah
I've met men from Portugal I hate them
and he spoke yeah who Sac said and I was
just I was obviously not paying
attention but I'd been there for a long
time so I was in I looked like a I
hadn't showered for weeks I looked just
awful and I'm thinking oh my God like
you're we don't have policemen like you
wow and I'm just signing the thing and
then when we got to the core I thought
oh no I've signed the wrong date so I've
stood in the box and they're giving me
grief and I said look I've signed the
wrong day I am human everything else in
my statement is completely correct but I
have signed my instructions on the wrong
day and that's totally on me I've also
put my number down if the guy from
Portugal wants it well this is this is
where they got me so then after at the
end of it they said what congratulations
you've passed with all the rest of it
and then they've got the Portugal the
Portuguese came in and I was like oh
hello
I looked horrified
and I'm like hello
anyone you're right in his accent and it
wasn't Portuguese
oh God no I'm I'm you see it Harry I was
like
oh and I just then it turned though I
didn't I thought oh I don't like you
anymore but it's true like I was like
how did it feel knowing he'd duped you
oh did you feel foolish
I don't like to be like made to feel
stupid but it was quite funny like I
took it on the chair and just went did
it give you an appreciation I suppose
for what the victims and well the
criminals rather that you've duped go
through like because at that point I
don't know had you done that much at
that point at that point no I haven't
been deployed and you know it I have got
people that I've been portrayed and I
feel really bad even to this day I feel
bad oh and then there's others I'm like
because of it's you people like you that
have been convicted that's what I joined
the police for and that's what I wanted
I wanted people like you to be taken off
the streets but then on the flip side
there's others and I'm like I think
about it all the time and I say I talked
to Ben about it I should I keep saying
Ben's my partner and I'll talk to him
all the time and I'll be like yeah but
sometimes I think about that and he's
like that was like 15 20 years ago why
are you thinking about that and I'm like
well
you're just an idea like what's where
are they in life now what are they doing
now
that you still have that in you though
because if you didn't well then you're
kind of a sociopath really if you don't
like have any emotion even if people are
doing wrong you have no compassion at
all that would mean that you're in the
police for the wrong reasons instead of
the right reason so and I have watched
some documentaries or in films where
there's like movie storylines where
Donnie Brasco even this uh for those who
don't know was a cop who went into the
mafia and then ended up sort of really
liking some of the guys he's trying to
take down but even then like that was a
different level
um you know I'm sure that some of the
people that when you like you say you
get to understand the reasons why
people all where they are and it changes
how you're perceiving the crime at the
end of it I suppose yeah there's been
operations where I'm infiltrating gas
you think you do you look at them and
think you could have been something or
you see the potential it's literally
circumstance they we're an it sounds
awful but a lot of it
[Music]
they'll be in the pub and they'll be
talking about what they're going to do
next I'm thinking if only you just can't
make it that day like and you can't go
and carry that out you won't get done
for it but you I know you're going to go
because you think they're all your
friends and you're all buddies and
you're looking out for each other
Ice Cube said it best uh there's a line
he says in the song where he goes they
give us guns and drugs and then wonder
why the [__] we are Thugs and it's like
a class issue as well isn't it and did
did you ever feel like
there's a that like did that Dawn on you
that this is almost a deliberate thing
here
like I didn't
when I was in honestly I was so I loved
my job I thought it was the best thing
in the world and I never went home and
thought I wish I didn't do that today I
wouldn't name a fault can't wait to go
back but I can't wait to be I hope they
redeploy me or if like times they would
say that they might stop index and they
might not do it anymore I'd be like I
hope they do a couple more just to see
if we can push it a bit further and I
liked it but I liked my I thought it was
brilliant
but it's now I've left and I look back
and I'm like actually some of that's not
why did I do that like oh that's a bit
weird but you know the person you said
you were particularly reminiscing about
the that one person you talked to your
husband about your partner
what was it that made you feel
you know
so I'll tell you what the job was and
you'll go oh my God
it was a festival job
and they it was around the time where
there'd been lots of bad pills on the
market and people were dying from taking
these pills so they deployed myself and
another UC into a festival I gave us a
Winnebago but at the time we're like
where did they go what festival and I'm
not I'm not a festival type girl it does
feel like a fun job but it was fun like
that's my worst nightmare Festival I
need a shower and so they gave us a
winner another job where I don't get a
shower yeah but no to be fair the
Winnebago had a shower
um but it was it was for all and it
wasn't in London it was out it was up
north and it was to buy drugs at a
festival which as you can imagine is not
a difficult job to have I mean can we
arrest everybody here yeah it was like
you walk into the dance tent I mean I'm
not gonna lie some of the music was
pretty decent and you'd walk in the
dance tent and you go well
it was literally like shooting and
fishing which one are we gonna go with
her because everyone's going in that
seems so pointless it's so pointless but
we've got obviously got crazy results
absolutely crazy and it was a crazy
results what kind of what you huge
amount of drug um we took a lot of drugs
off
off that for sale and but there was one
guy in there that was he was organized
crime he was in there he was he was a
proper dealer I didn't really have any
sympathy for him outside of it but there
was another guy and it was just
literally we looked at him and we'd seen
him serving up and we went over and said
to him got anything and he went yeah
what'd you want and he didn't have
enough on him he only had a little bit
so he took us back to his tent
service up on his 10 and I said and I
remember like thinking and saying we
spoke I can't remember exactly the words
but I said to my colleague he's young
him like you know along them lines and
he went yeah but everyone was young but
like we just thought he was a bit Young
and he got nicked obviously for
possession with intensive Supply it
served us up and it went to court and a
lot don't go to court but he went to
court and he was a student a law student
oh and his dad was a lawyer when we got
to call he was stood there and honestly
I just felt I felt like I definitely had
to swear but oh you are I just felt like
[__] I thought this is this is this is
this is really messed up like he's not
yes he is a drug dealer he served me up
but he's not a drug dealer what you're
saying is his life wasn't planned I've
had a deal drugs for the it wasn't he
wasn't a no-ho bar he was someone who
was probably doing it on the side to me
and I don't even think I would of course
he said he didn't do it outside of the
festival I actually believe he didn't I
don't think he was a drug dealer outside
the festival I think he's got himself
some gear and he just thought I can mark
up on this because we're in a festival
and that's literally it
um I mean how many people probably do
feel like oh yeah I just and I just felt
awful and I remember going to court and
looking at him and I felt so bad did he
look you in the eye no you won't look at
me
and his dad his dad did but I actually
wanted his dad look at you like he was
angry dad's angry but I kind of
understand why I think he was probably
equally as angry of his kid for being
stupid and doing it but did you have to
give a statement on the stand or
anything like that I didn't have to in
the end they asked to go and then I
didn't have to give Granny enough to
give everything do you remember what you
got or anything like that you went to
prison but I don't know where you got
[__] me yeah
and then I thought just and obviously
then that's his career a lot of stations
yeah they literally scooped his tent up
oh right okay so it was it was yeah but
it's not like yes he was serving up at
the festival he definitely was I
witnessed him doing it and he served me
but not outside of that and I'm not
saying that would a criminal record
prevent him from being a lawyer I think
so yeah he would have got kicked out of
uni yeah
I mean at least he's got his uh Rich
lawyer died yeah I don't want to feel
like do you know what I mean though
money's good yeah yeah that that was
wealthy but I just felt bad yeah you
know and as a parent as well like if
that was my child
and my daughter doesn't have absolutely
everything she's 18 and she knows
everything
um if that happened to her I and it was
literally like a an isolated weekend and
her whole life now is not ruined because
I know he can pick it back up but the
life that they'd planned Now isn't going
to plan I would feel really crap about
that I'd seen a kiss in America where
there was a they picked this like very
good looking policewoman who's a young
policewoman to be like the girlfriend of
this guy and next thing he knows she's
going to get drugs for her and then when
he gives them to us should I got you and
like that's a sort of like crap that I
think rubs people up the wrong way
because it's like you're basically like
any lad who would do that you know what
I mean like for a good looking girl he's
funny because when you're like people
always thought don't forget I was a lot
younger than I am now and I weighed
about three or four stone lives I am now
and I didn't have lines or anything like
that but when you're younger and you're
it sounds bad but you're giving men or
males attention and a little stroke on
the arm a little giggle at their stupid
joke they they even do what you want
them to do
this is how easy it is I wouldn't yeah
yeah well we'll see a million percent of
the you know that men are motivated by
women yeah like we are and uh I remember
even being like 18 19 years old thinking
I want to make money and my dad's saying
why do you want to make money so I can
get women yeah you know what I mean like
so like if if a girl at that age I
remember girls when I was going out in
Newcastle asking can you get some cup
and stuff like that like and it does
make you go and you had like probably uh
give us five minutes like you know um
from our perspective when you're doing
it in a covert capacity obviously there
needs to be intelligence you can't just
go up to a random guy and go can you get
me and he'll go yeah and then that's it
because that would be entrapment
um but so it would be that easy though
is the point but if I know that it's in
there and I've got a pretty good idea
when you're serving it up and I'm not
making him do something they wouldn't
ordinarily do and they're willing to
serve me up because they normally do it
and that's fine and that that is that's
just how it works like it's more to do
with clubs and Pub work than Street
stuff streets no one's looking at 31st
streets like that's just
um but I had another job where it was at
this is actually awful but um it was a
cannabis job which sounds it sounds bad
but it was on a very very large scale
um and
two other UCS to try to nut into them
this this gang and they've been bumped
they've been told to literally F off
copper like they knew they were all it
was brilliant it's genius and they were
like can you go and I said yeah I'll go
and I thought I was nervous about that
because I thought what if I I'd never
been bumped I'd never come back without
buying before oh so you had a good truck
oh yeah like yeah is this your ego
partly the player you're like I wanna I
don't want to don't want to fail yeah
I'm like I want to like I want to be I
wanted to be a part of The Clique I
wanted to stay with them the bigger the
bigger boys
um
and I went to this I was just sneaking a
snooker Club
it's really nice just playing pool yeah
and I've pressed the but yeah to press
the Bell to get in
and then they opened the door
electronically opened obviously because
they had CCTV everywhere their operation
was pretty good actually and I went in
and then there was like snooker tables
no balls no cues I was like
what is this and there was another door
so I just kind of shuffled to the other
door pressed the Bell then I was lit
through another door and then I was
locked between two doors
one door had like a little hatch in it
and he'll open the door he's like what'd
you want
20. because I don't really know what I'm
doing it I'll give you one minute and he
serve me up I was like oh
Wicked come out as I was quite happy
because I knew two had been and they the
other two had been bumped and I hadn't
so I was really happy so I just went
skipping off down the road
got back down a white I didn't know
tomorrow I go back and I was like yep go
back tomorrow went back again and when I
went back on the second one and I've
knocked between these two doors the guy
went to me um uh where'd you live then
and I was like oh I live at such and
such live with my nan because I thought
you know my name no one knows my nan do
they if I sadly with a boy they might go
who's your boyfriend like so good idea
because I'm in this area and I'm not
around here and he went so why did you
walk yesterday when you left why did you
walk up and say and he gave me my route
back and I thought
does he know that because if no one was
following me no the teacher seriously
don't know they had cameras on the
buildings like in the surrounding area
of this this Tennessee tennis club this
snooker club and I thought but I could I
didn't know that then and I went what so
if you'd hopped in a van close by yeah
oh they would probably let me back in
and give me a kick in and I was like oh
cause I had to go to my friends
um and and I was like ah does he know
that and I couldn't work it out and what
served me up when that's our fault I
need to like walk down the way that I've
just said I live
and when I got back and I said he said
he asked me about the way I walked and
he knew where I'd gone and they were
like what that they didn't know the team
didn't know either so they sent A Night
Team out and then that's when they saw
they had CCTV on all the flats in this
area like their own CCTV for their own
operation
um and then I went back again and then
this time he opened but they didn't know
who it was they had a good idea but they
weren't sure and then this time they
opened the whole door to me and yeah it
was amazing in there he had all these
and I was like
in Barcelona I went last year I wanted
to get myself some you know some weeds I
was like okay how do you do this because
I didn't realize it wasn't legal over
there so there's these like built just
like you've just described as well yeah
through these big massive doors and
there's a guy like what do you want and
then and then like all right where are
you from you know you have to ask all
these after all these questions and then
eventually they open this door
um one of the most lovely places I've
ever been to me like I'm like you I I
felt like it was better than this like I
was like wow okay then
um but yeah like the
it feels like that sort of when they've
got it locked down like that you have to
be very convincing before the election
so you must have been Golden Girl at
that point oh they were very happy but
then they kept buying it buying keep
buying keep buying this went on for
months wow and he was like why did they
leave it that long because they wanted
to know who else was involved in it
there was so much to it they were proper
organized crime group it was really cool
not cool but cool for me to work on it
um and he went I want to take you out
and I was like oh that was a matter of
time before this
this become a thing oh wow and um I was
like oh maybe maybe
I love it when you do this sorry no
because it helps us imagine how you won
them over ridiculous I am yeah
um and I was like oh is that give me a
number and I'm like no you give me your
number because now I've got some work
I'm thinking oh got intelligence because
the geeking means like geeking out there
I'm now going to get go back with her
phone number and he went all right so
put his number in my phone
um he did ring his phone from my phone
so then he did have my number
um not my real number obviously
I think yeah but we call it a dirty
phone okay
um and
off I went again and then they said are
you comfortable wearing a y like a
camera
I think well I am because like he's very
the guy is very very comfortable with me
now like he's as the door opens there
and he's vest he's like
you're really playing
um what was he like specifically he was
a car did you ever end up going out or
anything no no
I didn't mean that in a real monkey
sense I meant like as part of this whole
no no so it didn't go that far then no
and then I was like well I said yeah
I'll wear it because I thought he's
quite cool with me now and so I will
warmer camera they were very happy with
all the because when he opened the door
you could see their whole setup it was
incredible
um so we've got some good imagery got
you know we've got his number now which
is all brilliant work and then when they
were gonna go and Nick him or Nick them
they wanted me to go in and buy
to see what's in there leave and then
they were all gonna storm it to Nick him
or Nick the group that was in there
depending on who was in there and off
I've gone bought the gear come back out
and I'm like yeah he's in there and this
one's in there that one's in there and
then my phone rang
and it was him and then I could hear
them like raid in the play I could hear
the police on the phone radio because
he's on the phone to me and he stopped
the phone and then I'll get down I had
his stuff are these guys oh my God oh my
God I never thought that was the last
time I heard from him but he was like on
the phone oh it's really nice to see you
that is mental I'm like yeah
you can go I just love the fact that
you're like just too late I'm not
walking away
yeah that was a good guy I enjoyed that
because they were tied to other crimes
although I was only buying cannabis they
were tied to a lot of other horrible
stuff you don't have a setup like that
by accident not from Cannabis yeah
that's why I made the joke about the
craziest playing pool because that's the
type of [__] where we've seen these
these people do physical harm to people
clearly yeah they were they were into
trafficking you're not that scared for
not like for cannabis yeah you know what
I mean like there's you're locking shut
down for a good reason and
um yeah traffic and you mean like human
trafficking girls and stuff like that
did you ever deal with anything like
that no I was present when it happened
when there was some things going on
um where I was on the arm of other UCS
where they would be doing their work and
I would just be the girlfriend oh okay
so you had the other cover that's how
good I was I was just the Dixie
girlfriend
so like because they need these men to
have uh plausible stories yeah so you
acting as the girlfriend uh
did you uh what kind of things happened
in those scenarios then a lot of it was
in not in English so a lot most of the
time I had no idea what was going on Wow
and I would just do you know what
actually there was one where I actually
couldn't believe how many women are
involved in it because in your brain or
what we see it's all about these gangs
of men and and it's not all men they're
all women involved in this and women are
more trusting aren't they and they will
literally be like the hook to these
young girls and it'll be a woman saying
come and come here so this is what
Andrew tab did I don't know if you know
who Andrew T is but yeah he he got his
like mean girl uh by his own admission
to be the one to then contact the girls
and tell them how great it is and then
when he went to Romania he had um a
former policewoman working for him as
the head you know the girl who basically
keeped all these other girls in lane and
even Epstein you know like he obviously
had um Gillian yeah
um because you almost they do the dirty
work for these kind kind of people you
know yep
it's true you don't imagine it do you
think it's just big horrible bad men
but you have to you have to make them
care almost and make them feel like
they're part of it so there's this thing
that I learned about coercion like I
didn't really understand what that meant
until the last few months of like you
it's almost like Stockholm syndrome type
thing where you make these girls feel
like they're a part of something or that
you care about them and that you'll look
after them and yada yada meanwhile
you're just using them for all the money
but they they've had such bad lives
before they get there that often this is
some of the first times they've
experienced what feels like a man who
cares in any way shape or form yeah
um so yeah and I think as well they'll
probably feel like
leave then what where do you go from
there then yeah where's the security
yeah we know right now I've got a job
I've got a guy here who yes he's [__]
other women but essentially he's daddy
or whatever they're calling him and they
they feel like that's the best option
because of the horrible life they've had
and a lot of that's why the these men
pick girls who are from rough
circumstances in like Eastern European
girls and stuff like that yeah I think
I think I I think I think that's
probably happened for decades and
decades again it's only now we're all
talking about it but let me it's taken
us till now I guess to catch up to these
kind of people you know the internet is
helping us actually like document that
sort of stuff it's a double-edged sword
isn't it with the internet because in
one breath we're talking about it and
it's brilliant that we're talking about
it so people go actually that's not
normal and then the other side is the
internet's uh facilitating it because
they are able to reach more people
they're you know you can reach
so many more people that have to
physically go to these locations because
that's what used to happen you'd
literally physically go to places and
like these criminals would infiltrate
young girls who are in poor
circumstances personally just it's
online it's actually it's online they're
probably able to get way more women on
scale because that message that you send
like as we've seen with some of these
cases now that are being documented
they're sending them to hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of young girls
yeah it's crazy as you mentioned earlier
you were younger and you could obviously
make yourself look even younger yeah
which made you an ideal candidate for
um catching some of these horrible uh
men out there who are looking for these
young girls yeah what was that
experience like it's one of the stories
I was sent to there was an area where
there was a lot of sexual crime
happening against women
um and it was progressing to rape and
stuff like that and they said it was in
Brixton and they said Dan we'll Chuck
you out if you don't mind it normally on
a Friday Saturday night we think we know
who it is
um we've got we've had surveillance on
him but he hasn't done anything while
we've had science on him but if we Chuck
you out we reckon he'll take you and I
was like fine but in my head although I
know why I'm there I'm thinking it never
happened because it don't happen I've
been there loads of times these don't
happen
and then the night one of the nights I
was deployed they said we've got him
he's and you never wear any piece ever
but on this one they let me wear an
earpiece purely because we're in comms
and they said we've got him he's coming
out of this Pub and I was like Wicked
like this I wasn't even expecting to see
him they're like go like just do your
things I've gone down this road it's a
bit dark
got my handbag I've just chucked it on
the floor making it I'm a bit drunk and
he's come over and I'm thinking oh my
God he's kind of actually like
we're on here and um I'm sorry it's just
the excitement from you it's so Twisted
isn't it what do you think about it I
want the result yeah this is amazing and
I'm like oh yes and he's come over and
I'm thinking here we go he picked all my
stuff up give it back to me in my bag
didn't want to touch with you guys so I
was like
I don't know if I'm really really
offended that you are I'm not suitable
for your
or really believe that you've not done
it but when I got back to the Nick they
all thought it was hilarious like they
like that is the funniest thing ever
like they are quite so and it's him he
didn't want did you ever get him yeah
they did but not with me because I
weren't good enough he looked at me and
went oh no Thanksgiving back
but like whether that's like when I got
back they all just was cracking up oh
well they're taking the picture no you
can't you must be uh yeah they're like
you're too old for him now and I'm like
shut up I'm not
well
um but that was like maybe it was just a
big call from the you know but then
another job and like yes that was a
serious job but there was another one
where they said
um it's uh and eventually embal on it
um
there's a guy he's committed over 120
offenses on school girls and it's all
the same school uniform
some of the girls were a repeat victim
well you say things it was and I'm like
whoa yeah 120 offenses on school girls
yeah what what does that mean in terms
of like because not every offense is the
same is that right like yeah so I was
saying like one attack could be like 10
offenses for example does that mean are
you talking about 120 individual
incidents
how can that be so he there was he was
CCTV aware they had one image of him and
it was so grainy he couldn't make it out
some of the girls were repeat victims so
not because he knew who he had attacked
he didn't he just saw the school uniform
that was literally it but there was a
couple of girls that had been attacked
and then changed their route to school
and he got him again
and he didn't he just had no idea that
he'd already done it what was the extent
of his sort of getting them what were we
talking about some he started off with a
bit of touching you know over clothes
touching and then each one was getting a
bit worse okay but the one so uh the
worst one was the one that happened to
me which is good that it was me and not
one other girl okay they said basically
look we've tried surveillance we've
tried absolutely everything we can think
of but we just can't get this guy he's
just too aware
um we're going to put a decoy out you in
the school uniform and see if we can get
him so for two weeks I stood at this
particular bus stop and my phone my
dirty phone rang and it was the senior
investigator and she said index come
back to the safety and we've tried but
obviously he's not taken the bait so I
was like okay so it's Friday morning I'm
walking back started to walk back and
for some reason I just like Turned like
this and I saw this man creeping like
that behind you know the way it's got
like a wall then a bush above it it was
like creeping around it like this
but I didn't think anything of it and
then I heard like this like tap in and
as I went to turn he's got me around the
throw and he's just pulled me to the
floor
and ejaculated all over me
but I
I was in shock of course because I just
was not expecting it I really didn't
think you would get like I didn't think
it would happen but there was a safety
team on that so that if he did get me
they would come and get him so we had
someone in that house we had been men
coming oh and it felt like he was like
he was on The Truman Show he didn't
realize it because he didn't know but
they got him and um you said he grabbed
you by the throat and pinned you down
how quick did it go from him first
grabbing you to the end of the incident
he so he grabbed me from behind and then
he likes
was there
and he was masturbating with me so he
got him to the point of oh you needed to
be out and then he just all over me
right okay so this is a mentally
traumatic event for any woman even I
would assume a woman who was sort of
prepared for it to some degree
when you're leaving that moment after
they've grabbed him I'm assuming they
pounced on him yeah
okay don't worry Danny we've got we've
got him you know you go away and sort
yourself out
what was that moment like for you to
because on the one hand you've done an
amazing job yeah you've gotten a
predator away from real endangered kids
but on the other hand you're probably
feeling a bit not good I would I
I don't get all the clothing off of me
they needed to take a proper statement
and I obviously I write a statement
myself but they have to take a proper
victim statement
um but it's the same old thing where
they went back he was obviously taken
away I was taken to a different place I
got all the clothing and everything else
and then they reviewed the camera
footage quick to see what we could
because he's not always guaranteed what
you're going to get like angles are
terrible you said the camera was poking
behind you right behind me so we had no
idea what where's that on your jacket or
something one bag oh wow but you don't I
don't know what angles I'll get if it's
at the front I'm happy because I know
it's going to be like probably getting
someone's face okay on the back you
don't know no idea
um but we've got what they called the
money shot of him unzipping and we got
the whole thing of him so he's you know
his intent was quite clear
um
but I was told how great it was again
positive reinforcement yeah so it didn't
necessarily affect you in the way that
maybe people out there would think it
might I thought I'd done a good job and
I I genuinely that's probably one of the
best jobs I've ever done in my career
because I there's cheese as it sounds I
did make a difference because absolutely
I got a letter from a couple of letters
but one of them in particular from the
one of the girls mums and she said it
was so like and I'm not an emotional
person I don't cry much but I did nearly
cry out that one really and she'd said
that the little girl had she was one of
the girls had been done twice and she
now the little girl knew that he'd been
put in prison or had been arrested she
could now sleep at night she was no
longer taking sleeping tablets and she
didn't wet the bed anymore
and I thought that's actually I just got
like Goosebumps yeah I felt like that's
what I joined for you don't think that
concert you don't see them go I want to
join the police to make it you don't
think that but ultimately you do want to
because why else would you join that's
amazing police work and look I mean I'm
sure like anyone who's been through
anything like that or just this is what
we appreciate about the cops you know I
mean this is the good work that cops do
and that's the the ugly side of the job
where I mean no no person out there once
I go through that but you did that so
that other people could be safe and
that's really you know we appreciate you
people like that and um yeah who have
gone through that and to just not have
the aftermath that a lot of people would
have done you must be very resilient I
think as well
um
I was I was really lucky to have that
job I was going through a very messy
divorce at the time and if I never had
that job
um my job where I could be a different
person I was living two lives and if I
never had the other life
I think the divorce would have wrecked
me like so that was your outlet yeah I
could literally go to work and be my my
Alter Ego okay whatever that might be
for the day I could be my other person
but I think I'm like divorce is so
traumatic isn't it it's awful like it's
it's hardcore and I don't want to give
it airtime because it's not worth it but
I mean there's people who genuinely
commit suicide through that it's so hard
especially when you've got children
involved it's like awful and I was
really fortunate to have the job that I
had that I could just literally put that
to one side and not have to think about
it and literally until I come home well
that's a really interesting Dynamic of
your life then because on on
the one hand you're going out there and
doing this sort of thing but on the
other hand you are a normal person who
has a has a life at home so how did the
undercover work conflict with I mean I
did that have any impact on why you got
a divorce or yeah no definitely he
didn't know I did and uh found a phone
and thought it was someone else and the
best bit is if he'd seen the guy the
real guy that was behind the messages he
would have been like Ugh so he phoned
the dirty phone which you know in many
people who cheat on their other half
have a have a secret phone yeah my Mia
calls it the bat phone
um but so he assumed that this was
Europe then all good I understand that
you're not supposed to tell people what
you're doing but equally a lot of people
would have assumed that you in that
scenario would have been open with your
partner why did you keep that from him
because literally I was so not to tell
anyone um and the only person who was my
dad and that was only because he if
something happens to you
they need to ring someone they can't
they don't want to ring someone to go
she's been doing this and this has
happened
um so my dad knew what I did did you
tell him once you found the phone yes
and would you believe that
uh
I don't know no he didn't believe it and
to be honest it was I think for both of
us it was just a good out it was a good
point to go okay there was nothing to
fight for it was very convenient and and
whether or not you're telling the truth
I guessed uh you know the the trust
issue if if it's there it's always going
to be a problem isn't it so I mean look
uh that must have been really difficult
to go through such stress while then
risking your life out on the streets the
way you were even if you are resilient
you're a single woman after that yeah
what what was that like going from being
in a relationship to learn that and then
you're also running a cover cop
it was hard I had my daughter there and
so it was really hard for child care
like oh wow
because you're a night shift in all
sorts right yeah like you're in whatever
time you're required you need to be
there don't you so and a lot of it is
late afternoon evening work because
that's the nature of the job
um mum guilt would be horrific like so
explain mom go oh God like it's the
worst girl ever you'd I would literally
put her to bed my mum would come over
and then I would go off and do whatever
it was I was doing like buying
whatever or not always buying sometimes
I was just infiltrating
um and then I'd get home two hours
before she wakes up and then I would get
ready for school and then I'd be going
back to work to do something else so I
was literally living on like I I wasn't
eating and I wasn't sleeping much and
anyone who knows me knows I like a lot
of sleep
um
and I was just I would miss school
things like all the time every school
thing I would miss
and then I'd feel really bad like really
bad I'd say to the teachers I'm not
going to be able to make parents evening
but at the same time I needed to work
because I needed the money because I'd
left the family home with Amelia so I
had to go and find another house you
sort of split yourself as two different
people yeah
was there moments where that Mongol
would override so let's say you're in
you're in the van you're on the way to a
job and then would you have these
moments all like of worrying about am I
there enough I'm missing her I want to
be there for I'm missing this and it's
not or were you able to just switch off
and be quite
completely this different person yeah
the latter I would just not even think
wow
and I do that quite a lot with not not
so much now because I overthink quite a
lot so I'll think about things from then
and like start thinking about it now and
then Ben will be like what and I'm like
yeah but oh maybe I should like
that's mental I've heard Fighters say
things like this before I interview a
lot of Fighters and they're about to go
into a cage and beat the crap out of
another man and oh he he beats Thermo
and they like there was one guy who gave
a famous speech where he was like I've
got a kid on the way I've got this
happening I've got that happening yeah I
don't give a [__] all I want to do is
get in there and do this yeah you have
to get yourself into that frame of mind
yeah you know think about the job in
hand absolutely because when it's life
and death you can't you can't uh I
assume you can't put yourself in a
position where there's vulnerability
there's any weakness there's any because
if you're doing that you're not then
going to perform no yeah I I'm very like
well I was very like that where I would
just completely forget about it and then
when I like kind of left or when I did
have time off I massively over
compensated like to a whole new level oh
did you struggle to say no to your kids
are you soft I'm not no I'm not I'm the
strict one oh no I'm the strict one but
I don't go without anything in terms of
when you're dealing with these feeders
and you're trying to bring them down I
think you mentioned something somewhere
when I'm reading up on you about people
you never thought it would happen with
was there a cop
am I right and thinking there was a cop
who had something on his computer or
whatever yes I did actually someone told
me this recently it's not um I don't
believe it's in the press okay somebody
that I knew personally who I thought was
a great great copper really brilliant
copper
is there in prison for uh in decent
imagery you can barely see that I I I
you can barely believe it I genuinely
can't I would never
um when when my family my mind it was my
dad who told me he said you don't want
to believe what has happened and he told
me because my dad knew him as well and
said you're not going to believe what's
happened it's and told me that and I was
just like
yeah
I I had a similar moment actually well
not quite the same but there was a guy
who um you know like you have your main
circumference and you have the odd the
one who every like you say I'm like once
every six months and you'll just appear
in a bar and you'll be like oh you're
right mate and he was a guy who used to
work with a friend in my circle and I
kind of knew him but didn't know him
well we knew that when he went to
Amsterdam with my mate that he came back
with like granny porn DVDs and we were
all rinsing them for it like yeah
[__] weirdo but like it was a it was
a talking point of fun we used to just
rip him off for it and um and yeah
um my mate sent me a link the other day
been found with uh indecent images of
children or uh thousands of them on his
computer and it when you've encountered
someone like that and to me I knew it
was weird but like obviously you're just
it is a moment where I think people
don't realize how how traumatic it is
for like I know this guy
um I think he was adopted like the
parents the people around who were
impacted by because you the families
often get so spoken about as if they
were in on it yeah you know like and
that's kind of I feel sorry for those
kind of people as well who are
inadvertently affected by these creeps
um because they sometimes commit suicide
as well because it just brings down a
whole family well everyone says well how
can you not know but you don't know yeah
sometimes obviously sometimes you do
know and you like you said you think
although a bit weird a bit of a weirdo
or like a granny porn or whatever did he
buy that seriously like is in like a
serious
look we were all we used to laugh about
it because like he was like because
one went away we knew that we were like
they weren't Amsterdam so like we knew
that they were dodgy right they were
like they'd have a look at the windows
and whatever and one of my mates came
home with MILF porn and we were laughing
about that but then he was like he
thinks I'm bad he's in a guilf pawn and
that was just like a funny moment when
you're having a paint with the lads
completely left my mind never thought
about it again until my mate I haven't
seen this guy in like 15 years since I
was a young and you know
um but yeah it was like a really
mind-blowing moment and again people
think they'd know and they they don't
know and that's the thing I think is the
most entertaining thing about this for
me in a in a fascinating way because I
remember talking to a webcam girl once
who was a friend of mine
um I was a friend before she became a
webcam because I was like [__] me you
got some balls doing that yeah but she
was kind of um
uh what's the word like she would tell
me like you'd actually be surprised at
what I'm getting asked for and I'd be
like what do you mean and she'd be like
some of them asked me for like school
pictures of me like from when I was
younger or yeah the last me to dress up
a certain way or whatever and
um and it she said it's just made me
realize how many people out there are
actually into this on a scale but you
guys would never think of and yeah you
know um
it does make you wonder what the
percentages are and stuff like that it's
I think yeah I agree I think that
especially like with the webcam stuff
and I I I watch all them documentaries
and stuff I love them I've been I think
someone weirdo because I'm like I like I
like all this stuff I want to know
what's going on out there because if I
know about it I can protect my kids
exactly and if I don't know about it
we filmed the show a few years ago
called um I can't remember what's called
now celeb trolls were coming for you or
something like that if something really
yeah some really really bad line but it
was literally we found the trolls that
were hunting celebrities that were
causing celebrities horrible stuff yeah
and there was one I can't remember the
girls the celebrity's name that's really
bad but she was on X Factor okay and
I can't remember and I'm really nice
very kooky really nice but the DM she
was getting from this guy were horrific
he was sending her pictures of grassy
areas like in the middle of nowhere so
you can imagine what he was saying he
was going to do to her on this grass and
then he was sending her other images of
like people with
uh injuries and we're saying I'm going
to do this to you and it was so bizarre
she'd reported it to the police
obviously nothing had happened so we we
found him
it was actually really good actually it
was a really good one because we
couldn't find him at first but as you
probably realized I don't like to lose
against the bad guy and um we had
Bennett found a picture on his social
media of this area so Ben did some
imagery intelligence and we worked at a
rough area but it was a new build so
there was no like mapping there was no
um you know databases where we could
find his address with his net we have
his name but we couldn't find where we
lived we knew where everything else
about and where his mum lived where his
sisters lived we know he had the best
girlfriend we couldn't find where she
lived either whoa so we had a pretty we
knew it was a rough area where a decent
geographical area but it was too too big
you know you couldn't just walk around
aimlessly
um and then we was following all their
social media sites and the girlfriend
posted a thing for sale on a buy and
sell group on Facebook
so I we had to speak to Legal sharp and
say can I buy this piece of kit
and they were like oh this is a bit much
and I said but if I buy it I can say
I'll pick it up
and they were like oh and the TV people
are like clapping and all excited like
yeah this is going to be amazing this is
so great TV so they legal went through
what they had to do and said yeah okay
you can arrange to buy this it was a
pair of Ugg boots you can buy the Ugg
boots so I messaged off my one of my
accounts I said oh amazing can I have
these boots I'll come and get them
tomorrow and she's like yeah sure she
marked them are sold I said can I have
your address I'll be there tomorrow when
she sent us the address I was about
seven hours away
so they were like you need to get a
flight there now get their crew all
their
um so I went and bought the boots and
when he I obviously just had they
couldn't film so I just had a microphone
and when I went to the door to buy them
he opened the door to me
oh my God it was I can't believe we'd
got it it was him
so then I've come back there because
they couldn't film it because it was
real
um I just do all these pieces to camera
and say what we'd just done and it was
him what was he like when you confronted
him well the next day we took we knew
what time he left for work Ben had done
surveillance physical surveillance on
his work address but he wasn't there we
knew where he worked but he hadn't been
there that's why we've done them it was
mental and um honestly what a couple
um
the next day we took her because I can't
remember her name it will come to me we
took the X Factor contestant outside his
address no with all the crew so when he
came out for work he came out and she
said you've got something you want to
say to me and he just legged it he ran
like a little cow with the ears he ran
back into his house but she was really
giving it she was like hello she was
really Posh hello I'm here do you not
have anything to say to me and people
were like what's going on but we and he
wouldn't apologize and the crew went and
knocked and said him look this is what's
happened we're here because you've done
this and TV people are very nice
um and he wouldn't talk he just he
locked himself away he didn't go to work
that day because we were waiting so when
he comes back out we'll ask him again
yeah I mean
it's it's a weird one because these
people who I mean I've had thousands
upon thousands of threats and DMS and
all sorts of weird [__] they are the
drugs of society and they are they are
and like let's be real no one ever is
sending hate-filled messages who's doing
better than the person that they're
sending messages to they they're they're
really miserable you know what I mean
they've got serious problems so on the
one hand sometimes I'll read messages
and I'll literally laugh out loud and
I'll be with someone I go this one just
said I'm fat you know and it's just like
a bit of a laugh but equally like it is
a sad existence so when people get that
obsessed with someone they probably need
locked up yeah yeah when they keep like
when they make that level of threat so
it's one thing calling someone a name
but this is like go out and message them
oh yeah and this chapter this is
harassment here two little girls and I
always think if that as a parent
if someone did that to my child I'd be
really upset and he's got kids so why I
would take his children off of me I'd
say like if you're if you're sending
someone death threats like that yeah the
stuff he was sending it was horrific
yeah yeah and that's what I'm saying to
that level of Darkness yeah you're not
fit to be a parent at me you haven't you
shouldn't be around little kids
especially not girls yeah you're
demented you're literally a stalker at
that point like so yeah it was good it
was good in so far as she was really
pleased with like getting his face and
he deleted all his social media
sometimes I go back and see if he hasn't
reactivated any of it so that's good at
least he nipped him in The Bard but we
was talking to another lady that was on
the show and she's we're not friends
friends but we you know we're keeping
concept here and there and she's in the
public eye and she gets so much hate
like I and she she does post it
sometimes she'll like repost what people
are saying to her and I just think that
I'm like
and a lot of it's from women and I'm
like why are you saying that to her I
don't get that like this whole women
should build each other up and stuff I
bet this is the same women that are
sending it like why are people so
hateful like just be nice if you've got
nothing nice to say just don't bother
saying anything one of my one of my
favorite uh I I had this uh guy who I I
just there's times where I'm like I take
a real shine of some of the insults
that's what that made me laugh you know
but there was one guy who literally
um sent me a really horrible nasty
message and I remember looking at his
profile picture and I'm not just saying
this the guy was one of the ugliest
humans I've ever seen in my life I
thought yeah I get why you're pretty
hateful you know but then
so he's laying into me on a mental
health level and I've been very open
about my mental health struggles in the
past and and then I looked on his
Twitter and I seen like tweets about
like how he's been struggling with his
mental health and yada yada and like
it's always me attitude and
um it's funny how like on a they're able
to separate what they're doing with them
still being the victim you know and if
there's one thing I've I've learned from
my time in this in this business the
last 10 years is how people will do the
shittiest things to people yeah but then
because no one wants to be the bad guy
in the life story they'll they'll um
reframe it they'll reposition it in
their head of well I only did that
because of he's this and he's that and
you know like they give themselves the
excuses and the outs like a serial
killer would you know when you say those
serial killers on the stand yeah they've
always got oh well he attacked me first
yeah you know six people like you know
um who do you think the worst person you
came into contact with without
throughout all of this where you are
like you might be the worst piece of
[__] I've ever met in my life the
schoolgirl scenario where he got me he
was pretty horrific because he's a
taxwell getting worse and there's not a
singled out in my mind he would have
done what he'd done to me to an actual
child I have no doubt about that
um I mean he thought you were a child
yeah was there ever a time that you
accidentally bumped into someone who
you'd see and so like you're now out of
being undercover but then you see
someone who knows you to be someone else
yeah and you catch them in regular day I
have that has happened once where I was
in Westfield at Stratford and it wasn't
my job it was a job where I'd been on
the arm of someone and
um I was walking I had the kids with me
and I was walking through Stratford
and he like looked at me and I like
looked him and I was like oh hello and
just carried on as if it was me from the
job
but it was fine because he just assumed
like kids and the kids had no idea oh
but they just thought I'd said hello to
someone that was a freak you know with
the kids right yeah and then that's when
I probably that was towards the end of
my career as well so that's probably
when I started thinking what am I doing
here like this is a bit stupid actually
like I've got kids if I and now I'm a
single parent and now I've got two kids
if something happens to me who's having
these kids
let me split and I know that's that I
get quite embarrassed even saying it but
that's it's my life and my kids do have
two separate dads and if I split if I
died they would be split
I don't want them to be split they've
grown up together they don't know any
life without each other
um but who would have them and I can't
ask if I couldn't have my parents have
them because they're older now they
don't want kids in like their
grandparents I don't want kids to look
after was that what made you want to get
out of the business one of the reasons
yeah I just started thinking about it
more I just it sounds ridiculous but I
just grew up and I started realizing
rather than I'd rather than not thinking
about it I started thinking about it and
before I didn't I just was told I was in
a disciplined Service as well so if I
was told to be somewhere at a certain
time I would be there at that I'd be
there and I'd do it and I'd do the job
I wouldn't say no because I'm being told
that's my job like you're going to be
deployed what you think
I'm gonna go oh no actually I don't want
to do it a lot of people do say they
don't want to do them because they're
not nice are they did you ever in all of
these drug deals and all of that ever
have men who tried to force themselves
on you or anything like that yeah my
first ever job that's a point I should
have given my card back and said I'm not
doing this anymore wow my first one
first ever covert op yeah he um
but that I mean I again I didn't know
any different at that point so I didn't
really know how they were supposed to
work and I was deployed in Tottenham and
um I was told just to establish a supply
of Class A all I knew was I wanted to
buy something I didn't even know what I
wanted to buy but I was dressed like
smack head I want for a better term
um and I went in The Bookies just sat
there fire EJ's looking around thinking
this is awful it was disgusting
and there was a toilet I'm not using
that because that was like and I got
chatting to this guy and I said oh you
couldn't help me could you my like I'm a
normal guy's not here and I ain't got
any more numbers and he went oh I'll
take your girl come with me and he went
come on and I was like oh all right I
don't know where I'm going because I'm
like oh yeah right then so he said we'll
get the bus and I'm thinking oh I can't
get the bus because I don't they think
I'm in this particular area and I don't
know where I'm going I said no I don't
like the boss like can we not walk and
he went oh come on then we walked and
then he was trying to sell me some gold
that he'd nicked from a burglary and I'm
in my brain the cop was saying get the
gold because we know he's the burglar
but in my covert life going no because
then you're not gonna have enough money
because he wanted me to buy it you might
not have enough money to buy the drugs
so I didn't know what and I was like no
I don't want to hear that maybe tomorrow
and I'm thinking I could get it tomorrow
because I'm a police officer
um and he took me to this house and he
knocked on out and then he said to me
before he got there he said um you've
got to chip me off and I'm thinking I
don't know what that means
I'm like yeah yeah yeah but I don't know
what any of this means and obviously now
I know it means he wants some of the
drugs that we're going to buy he wants
to take a bit all right okay but I don't
know what any of this means and and then
I'm thinking but if I chip him off I'm
supplying him with class A so
technically legally I would be a drug
dealer so I'm like I can't do that so am
I right I'm I'm just but I'm assuming
and correct me if I'm wrong that in the
event that you're doing this the law
doesn't apply quite the same way to you
or is it still all the same yeah still
I'm not allowed to give him drugs wow
okay yeah good like you go will she give
me and I'll be like oh yeah but no and I
don't think I'd get away with it wow um
he took me to this address he's knocked
on these guys come out and he's told him
what we want I don't even know what we
want but he's told him what we want and
then the guy goes back in the dealer
goes back in and he goes to the window
and then another guy even this there's
the dealer from the door and another
chap now at the window with their
knicker and looking me up and down like
and I thought oh they're just checking
me out to make sure I'm good I don't
know what I was thinking
whatever just give me the drugs because
I need to go and um
so the thing let's come back out is give
it to my mate from the booking shop at
betting shop and he's chipped himself
off and give me the rest I'll give you
the money and then he's give the money
to the dealer me and my mate from The
Bookies have said our goodbyes and if
I'd known now
at the end what I know now I would have
kicked off because he chipped off too
much but I didn't care at the time I was
like yeah yeah like just whatever but
now I'd have been like give yourself
back he's taking like this that much so
many of us said goodbye I've started
walking I am so happy with myself like
my first deployment and I've I've just
bought crack
and I see my pocket and I'm like
striding along the road in my little
happy self and the dealer from the doors
come it's like yo yo yo and I'm like
hello and he's like oh I'll walk you
and I'm like walk me where and he's like
I'll walk you to your house I'm like no
you can't I said my man will be there
and he will literally kill us and he's
like no I'll walk you and I'm like nah
you can't and he's like well I am and
I'm like oh and anyway where's the
where's the gear and I thought oh no
he's gonna rob me he's gonna rub me for
the thing and I finally just bought it
and I've started to panic and I said
I've plugged it
and he was like okay and he just left it
weren't it was in my pocket but he
thought I'd plugged it and then he's
walking with me and he goes so you've
got a man I'm like yeah yeah I've got to
go because he's like he's mental and
like he's gonna literally like when I
said a few horrible things and he goes
come with me and he's like pulling me
and I'm like oh no no and he's like got
my ponytail and he's like come on and
I'm like I can't have sex with you
I can't have sex with you and he's like
no no no they want that and he asks tell
me what you wanted and he was undoing
his trousers and he's pulling my head
down and I'm thinking
well now what
I'm in an Alleyway and if you know
Tottenham it's like a ladder if you look
at it from like the bird's eye view it's
a ladder so loads of Alleyways but I
could still see the road
and I'm thinking if I run
he's massive he was a good six plus and
if I run he's just gonna outrun me
I don't know what to do
and so he's pulling my head he's undoing
I thought I'll just bite it
and I thought if I buy it and then leg
it to the end of the alley I'm back on
the main road now so then
it's going to give me a couple of
minutes because he's going to be on the
floor
he's gonna be on the floor and if
someone bites your penis you've got to
be on the floor touch wood that's never
happened but um yes I mean at the very
best case scenario you'll be on the
floor yeah so I thought um that's that's
that was it that's the only thing I
could do at this point and um then a
vehicle screeched up at the end of the
road and these guys come out and he's
legging it down the alleyway and I'm
thinking what the [__] now why are you
doing this to me now like I thought is
this a test but it can't be a test
because none of them would know this is
happening and um then I looked at him
again and I thought I recognize you why
do I know you've been being in my safety
briefing
and I'd because I was all new and I was
all out of my depths with it I had a
phone in my pocket and it was a two-way
phone so they could hear everything that
was going on so my safety team at the
the knee could hear everything that was
happening oh and they'd obviously said
to go and get her because she's about to
get herself in trouble here and he gave
me a few words I'm not even called me a
few horrible names the guy and I was
like oh and the the guy that was undoing
his trousers so the guys run down The
Alibi is calling new names yeah he's got
to be you slay
the guy who wants the favor the dealer
he apologized to him he said sorry man
she wanted it and I'm like
oh but he didn't say sorry to me and
then that so that was the end of it we
went back and I was like I was like
thank you for coming to get me one this
is day one but then they sent me back
they let your mind going back again I'm
like no I'm fine now you won't try it
again so I went and kept buying from him
that was day one I should have probably
known that it probably weren't for me
sorry Mitch who wanted it yeah [__]
drug dealers just aren't very
trustworthy
honestly I gotta beat the room
no it was um
yeah but do you know when he got
convicted they said to him like
obviously in disclosure after telling me
it's a Cove operation
apparently he's face when they heard the
recordings and everything was like that
[__] like she was fuming that it was me
because it obviously yeah that's one
thing I've not really thought about is
the moment where
you reveal single woman reveal yourself
like the moment you show them or they
find out I mean you you kind of get the
a little bit of a buzz out of that I
would assume I'd kind of enjoy that
especially if I'm taking down this
horrible criminal who's attacking women
in back alleys yeah I mean I don't I'm
never there to see any of it did they
relay it here though yeah sometimes if
it's a good reaction I get told like
I've called you sure I called you this
and they called you that like I've been
to court before where
I like that with it was a pedophile case
actually and he did have the jumper and
the glasses
and when he when he heard me speak he
was like he looked like his whole world
he lost his because he was all like
quite and then when I spoke you in
like he couldn't believe it was because
he knew it was a covert operation but he
I don't think he really believed it was
real
um and he was just he was just stood
there in the box like
he couldn't believe it he was so shocked
but that was another one where you think
yeah do you know what I've done a good
day's work here because you're going to
prison tonight like you're
yeah I mean what do you make of the
amount of time that these people have
gotten when you look back the the people
that you put in yeah the the pedophile
staff and when they go to prisoners or
they are housed together they get put in
together it's kind of keep them safe
from the other guys yeah
they do and I get I totally get that
reasoning but I don't but
in the same breath like you're putting
them together they're kind of going to
share secrets right like that's the best
way to hide things because criminals do
make each other worse criminals in
prison a lot of the time you get an
education from Ladson who have been
inside yeah it just makes you more aware
it just it doesn't make sense to me to
put them together yeah
and then the sentencing is never what
you know it should be way more shouldn't
it and that's half the problem isn't it
our prison system
um
is it is it a deterrent I don't think so
I've not really honestly my knowledge of
the prison system is quite limited yeah
it's the sentences
not as heaven and when they're in there
you say I like
I was um
I can't remember there's a another
documentary Series where he goes to the
world's toughest prisons and some of
them are horrific like you would not
want to be going in there and then you
go to other ones and you're like that
looks like a Holiday Camp like it don't
look that yeah I mean I've interviewed a
guy who was in a Thailand prison it was
like 60 men in a room yeah like they're
ripping each other and it's just [__]
horrendous
um but then yeah like you see some of
the ones in England where they've got a
PlayStation in their room yeah blows my
mind yeah me too I can't why
yeah so you can have prisoners with
PlayStations but there's kids that don't
get a dinner it's very frustrating as
well when you see people getting like
treatment such as like new identities
and stuff like that you know
um especially people who kill children
and stuff and they're getting brand new
identities and yeah you're like what the
[__]
um
yeah that must be the only frustrating
bit when you catch someone like that and
you think and then you're getting this
are you like a limited sentence or they
come or they've been put back like put
away and then they get let out and they
do it again
we had one guy who had he was a
pedophile on uh probably 14 15 year old
girls and he part of his release was he
was not allowed any electrical equipment
like laptops or phones and stuff like
that in his house this was a long time
ago so but he'd made contact with uh
well me but he wasn't obviously me
um and
he'd been doing it at the library the
local library
you can't use the computers though yeah
[__] you know
is there a deck store and that's the
thing why are we releasing them do you
feel like just throwing away the key on
these guys is the only solution because
like that Louis Theroux documentary
really stayed with me because a lot of
these men in there were 50 to 60 years
old who had been repeat offenders for
the course of a lifetime and it's like
you ain't that that doesn't leave you
and there was one really interesting
interview where there was a pedophile
who kind of spoke out in a sense of he
was like look I've got this problem I
don't want to act on it and that really
blew my mind because he was like he was
like I know it's wrong I don't want to
do this I need help I don't know where
to turn yeah and he kind of admitted
like this ain't going to go away like
putting me in jail for eight years I
come out I'm still gonna feel the way I
feel and it's like to me it doesn't make
sense to give them a few years and
release them because you're just you're
literally letting a tiger out onto the
street basically it's like a wild animal
yeah uh in terms of your new business
that you have now with your partner uh
the Cyber investigation stuff you've
touched on it a little bit but what sort
of what's the day-to-day like what's the
juiciest things that you end up doing
like the pandemic
cyber crime just went nuts didn't it
because everyone was at home people are
bored people become desperate for money
so they would do things online okay so
it could literally be from one thing
could be like
recruitment fraud it could be literally
investigating where people whatever
person or an organization are pretending
to be recruiting people for a big
corporate company which happens a lot
what level of Fame do you think is the
highest you've you've known if you were
to compare it to a law a celebrity not
the celebrity okay I'm not saying name
the celebrity we're going to be clever
about this yeah
but let's let's say like to the level of
who's a celebrity on the level of
someone who you've worked with
world famous really yeah we'll talk
about Adele Beyonce type stuff yeah yeah
I can category but on that level yeah
yeah and what kind of uh things uh do
you do for the famous people generally
um mainly like what their sexual
appetite no no no it was actually it was
a relatively clean one really yeah
they're boring yeah
oh my God oh my God oh my God then the
world was that oh okay
um other ones can be like there was one
particular one where we had a purse an
athlete who had been away
preseason I say athletes obviously a
footballer he'd been away uh pre after
before pre-season and he hadn't actually
done anything wrong and I quite liked
him I believed him
but a girl had said I'm gonna release
this something he's like I don't know
how she'd have it because they said I
swear to you
I haven't done that I did talk to this
guy I know who she is I did talk to her
I did buy some drinks but he said and I
said to him look you need to tell me
everything if you don't tell me
everything I can't help you and he said
I'll tell you he said he told me loads
of other stuff there's not nothing to do
with the case he was in there so I
wouldn't tell you that and not tell you
this I've got yeah so he's giving you
stuff that doesn't look great about him
yeah he's not trying to be an angel no
he was like he said but this he said but
she's saying this and she's sending she
was sending pictures and he was like but
like it looks he's like I'm just sitting
talking to her but it looks bad
thought she's saying that then after
that and you know if he was his partner
you would look and go what I started
Kayla yeah because if you've got like
the beginning of a story and then she
claims the ladder to hear but she's got
some evidence that you knew her yeah
immediately it's more believable than if
she's never met you obviously and um any
I I we then I met him and we liked him
and I and I did believe him
um and uh he said but I need to she's
saying it's coming from her and then
there's a friend who's going in he said
but I don't know who this friend is
so we worked out who the friend was we
got all the information because they
were emailing from dodgy emails and all
sorts and so they're emailing so they're
not posting this online this is private
they wanted money
do you know what I don't even think
necessarily it was the girl so much I
think it was the mate who was and mate
the mate was male of the girl I think it
was more the mate that wanted blackmail
yeah
[Music]
um and we found out who it was and we
just said that we know it's you
we're asking you to leave it because
they are going to get their lawyers
involved and we know it's you we've
proven it's you through our methods
um and he was really happy with that
because he didn't want it to go crazy
it's like the last thing they wanted to
press involved he was living his private
life yeah and he couldn't stay private
you don't you don't want the hustle this
but that is he said and then he thought
we were like
um 999 he just could bring me for
anything and then he was like if only
once and he said um
things happened I was like what now
obviously I've gotten a bit of trouble I
was like what have you done I've had a
bit of a fire I was like
I can't help you with a fight he was
like but you've got police friends can
you not just ring them and say well
you're like um you like me don't you
like I'm a nice girl I'm like wow a nice
guy but I don't have any I don't have
that much weight for Paula said naive
the one there they don't really grow up
I really liked him but yeah he said some
funny things like he made um he was
trying to say
something and he went instead of saying
I've got an inkling who it is
said I've got an incline of who it is
yeah but but Ben
and like I had to kick Ben under the
table and say let's shut up this is a
premier league footballer on big money
as well a lot of money yeah but really
but do you know when they're just joking
I've got an incline who it may be and
yeah
I can come he did not play for Spurs
yeah so we deal with things like that
like just and they're little tiny jobs
but then we deal with other things like
we will look on like digital digital
vulnerability so we'll look at how
vulnerable is someone online oh wow so I
know people are very vulnerable so we
might be looking after people in the
public eye or it could be c-suite you
know for big companies we could look at
the CEO and did you guys
follow the mess in Greenwood story yes
what did you make of that because
obviously she licked all of these
um images videos and stuff and yeah the
voice clip it was brutal it was horrible
for people to hear a premier league
footballer speak in such a way to a
young woman like that who was in a
relationship with
it was mind-blowing yeah I did what I um
Ben actually didn't he was like I don't
want to listen to that really
um but
I just think
if I I don't know why she's now gone
back and that isn't she pregnant now the
rumor is that she's pregnant and they
are going to stay together and have a
baby and all of that but but obviously
like look the public have an opinion of
this guy and pretty much he's an [__]
horrible person but you're the one who's
actually got your hands dirty and been
involved with people like this and had
to talk to people who've done horrible
things
what do you make of a a victim going
back to the perpetrator and then having
a long life with them you know it is
their reform capable in your head or do
you think that this is a situation where
he cynically is like about I better keep
the scale close to me because yeah you
know because she was they were you know
they were going to press charges and
then all of a sudden everything oh no
actually everything's gonna be fine now
happy families what do you make of all
of that I just I don't know I've got two
sides I'm gonna sound like I'm sitting
on the fence with it I listen to the
voice clips and she's quite telling him
categorically no and he's telling her to
if this is obviously of covering myself
here but if that is really them two
speaking and that's what their people
are saying is you know it's been said
that is him and it's her she's saying no
and he's telling her to park it for him
because he wants to um and she say no
that's enough that should be him she
doesn't want to that's literally the end
of it
so then go back I don't know if that's
an you see the the pictures and the
bruises and the moth yeah it was like he
she had a really bloodied face bad face
this is a violent man is it has she gone
back genuinely voluntarily or has she
gone back
like coerced back I don't know
I don't know coerced meaning like like
as in
not control you may be a bit controlled
back like you know manipulated a little
bit back because she was strong enough
to release all of this stuff and to go
to you know the extremes of pressing
charges
but now done a complete flip wire what's
the complete flip I don't I don't know
what that could be
the uh I mean the again the rumor and
this is just completely what you hear
what you see on social media is he was
ending the relationship she then decides
okay well now it's not in my interests
I'm going to
have my day and show what you're really
like at that point he's then thought
[__] I need to get a hold of her and
bring her back closer to me than ever
because she's the one who's going to
take away the career yeah take away the
money all of that and and maybe on a
cynical level and this is just a
suggestion it's not me accusing anyone
maybe she's thinking you know you were
my chance at a a life of money and
wealth and fame and you were about to
take that away from me well I'm telling
you now that I've got I've got my
bargaining chip here and I'm willing to
use that so yeah we either stay together
and have that success or we're apart and
you're going to jail like you know and
that and unfortunately a lot of people
don't like to say that out loud you know
but the reality is is like
when you're the guy who has the money
and that in and I am certainly nothing
like Mason Greenwood but I have
experienced the way people can behave
when you reject them yeah and they feel
like they're losing their meal ticket oh
my God they say you know
fear the rough of a woman's scone [__]
me is you know what I mean so look if he
was I mean he clearly was a piece of
[__] in my opinion and uh he's backed
himself into what they both have backed
themselves into a situation which looks
really miserable from the outside like
that like if he's
the worst yeah
he was in that position what's going to
stop him from doing that again like if
you don't want it you don't want to
that's it but and then to bring a baby
into it the power Dynamic must be an
absolute shambles there because on the
one hand he needs her for his freedom
and she needs him for the paycheck are
they taking him back to the club now
that that unfortunately Manchester
United are now like you know when he
starts like leaking things into the
Press yeah and they just saw a baby
stepping it into he just to see okay how
they're going to do this or not you know
what I mean but what they haven't done
is Taurus contract up
so the one thing we know is they're
considering giving him a platform again
uh which is yeah that's crazy isn't it
because especially when you think about
so he's done that
how many fans are there of man united
across the world Millions so the police
have a number of very bad apples not I
want to call them more but I won't and
the whole country goes the police are
this the police the as a whole the
police and it's not the whole You've got
millions of followers of man united that
still support man united still go over
to all the games still watch them on
telly still buy all the shirts all the
memorabilia but you've got a ray pissed
alleged rapist on the team
no one's turning their back there are
they on the whole club well I I thought
that we would see a huge outcry and we
kind of did but time is a is an
interesting thing you know and they did
a vote on a really uh popular Manchester
United fan group on Twitter the other
day and those the sample was 170 000
votes yeah so I was like okay we're
gonna say 99 we never want to see him
play for Man United again yeah it was 47
versus 53.
and that
blew my mind to hear all those records
and say all that footage to see the
marks left on her and the clear abuse
she went through for then for that
amount of people to say yeah bring about
and the reality is is you know if if
that was a a bad footballer a terrible
footballer yeah who would never ever
done anything wrong but was just a crap
player it would be 99 get him out yeah
but but because he has talent and he
does have amazing talent that's where
the Forgiveness comes in and it's
mind-blowing to me like do you know what
and I'm kind of put myself down a hole
with this and now I'm trying to do my
whole
um level-headed thinking like that the
bits that were leaked obviously when we
have seen this in our work where you
there'll be bits put in the Press but
you won't see either side of it now what
she's obviously the bits that have been
like she's quite seriously saying no
it's quite obvious no he's saying to her
in not very nice terms no you are oh I
want it like it's quite obvious what the
conversation is and then she's posting
the pictures of the injuries and I'm not
saying I don't believe because I do
believe her but just plain Devil's
Advocate what happened either side of
that like so what was the bit before the
recording what was the bit after I've
heard things because obviously in my
position like people message you stuff I
know the family I know this and yeah and
I take everything with a grain of salt
that says all this but the the the the
the talk is it was a very toxic
relationship
all right and you know
um so does that mean she was perfect no
but does that obviously mean you know
obviously it doesn't mean that she
deserved anything that happened and he
he was obviously the aggressor in what
we see him but yeah I I hear your point
and that and um you know
it's just such a cynical thing to
experience but look we're gonna we're
gonna go to my final question because I
thoroughly enjoyed a day and I do one I
want to know this one from you which is
how would you like to be remembered
um
oh
I think that
I had the life that I live now is
we suffer from where I'm from lived we
could live you know I grew up on a
council estate
in dagenham it wasn't very nice I never
in a million years thought
there would be any TV where I never
thought I'd have a book that's mental
when I see it I laugh because I'm like I
can't believe anyone's even reading that
um I never thought I would live in Spain
you just don't do as a kid I thought I
would be the Workhorse I even in the
police I thought I would do my 30 years
and I never thought that I would have
the life I have now I never thought I'd
have kids and I've got two
um I don't know maybe just
we take risks quite a lot in our house
we quite we're Risk Takers so maybe that
maybe
you're arrested taker yeah you've
absolutely smashed it it's been a
pleasure
um a big thank you I'll put the link for
your book if people want to check that
out in the description and uh what a
story and I've absolutely loved chatting
with you thank you very much for having
me thanks so much that was Danny Brooke
on the true Geordie podcast thank you
very much and we'll see you on the next
one cheers
thank you
[Music]